as far as I can see most modern
depictions of women in media patronize
them I mean how does it feel for you as
a female woman of color that also
happens to be an immigrant like I
imagine that it doesn't Empower you or
make you feel particularly good either
no it in fact I feel like
the treatment based on your my color
based on my status as an immigrant
um it's as if it's a handicap that I'm
that just because I was born a woman
means I'm handicapped I feel like that's
how people look at me and it's it's not
with
and they're not looking at me with
encouragement but it's with pity and it
it makes me it makes me not it doesn't
make me feel empowered it makes me feel
discouraged and I think
this desire like you were saying the
cultural milia is that
is the rise of narcissism right and I
think that's partly what I talk a ton
about on my channel is that especially
amongst women
um the perspective has become seesawing
between I'm incredible and and and then
going the on the other side which
narcissists do all the time is that if
anything is wrong in my life the fault
lies with someone else and their desire
to bring me down and that entire
perspective creates a really hard shell
around you as an individual that is
almost impenetrable where if you need to
change and grow if you need parts of you
like Jordan Peterson would say like if
you need parts of you to die so that you
can evolve to the next level Nothing's
Gonna nothing is a lot gonna your
narcissism is not gonna let that happen
so we if we continue to patronize women
to you know patronize women patronize
people who live on the edges of society
per se even though they don't they don't
necessarily they're you know majorities
in a lot of ways
um we're going to create a culture of
people that refuse to change refuse to
grow and most importantly refuse to
negotiate with anybody and I don't know
if you come across this on online
because
I see this a lot and I specifically see
it with people that are like you know
acquaintances where there'll be a lot of
content that'll be like
um ignore the haters it'll say something
like you know forget the haters
um if anyone doesn't believe in you you
know
um f them like forget about them and
it's this this very interesting
perspective that like either someone's
with you or they're against you there is
no in between and there's no room to to
talk that out and you know there are
times that I'll say something on my
channel and I'll hear some criticism and
I'll hear some feedback and I'm like
okay maybe I was flawed in that
particular thinking and that's that's
fine this is a conversation in a lot of
ways but if but the perspective that
they're trying to sell is like no no no
no no
if you said it you were right all along
they just want to keep you down
and it's just it's it's like that's you
bearing your that's you digging your own
grave if you buy into that you are
digging your own grape because there's
not going to be a successful life that
you can live with that perspective
if people aren't taught to be able to
take criticism especially if the
portrayals that they see of themselves
represented in media never take
criticism if somebody does criticize
them then there's a clap back Boss [ __ ]
moment where they tell them exactly put
them in their place and tell them and
sure enough all along I mean we're
seeing this with the Lord of the Rings
Galadriel is just permanently in the
right we saw this with the Star Wars
with the fact that the female the new
female superhero there that she was she
taught herself and then immediately was
able to destroy everybody around that I
think eternals had some sort of weird
stuff like that in it she-hulks had some
stuff like that I mean Batwoman got
canned presumably because
um
who does that is that Warner Brothers
that do that one uh was it yes it was
Warner Brothers okay so Warner Brothers
it seems can't continue to piss money
away but Disney can so Warner Brothers
are binning things that they can foresee
might not make money because I mean this
is the
the long and short of it is that people
aren't going to go and see these movies
like when I think I I enjoy going to the
cinema but when I think about going to
the cinema and then look at what's
available for me to go and see I didn't
want to go and see Thor love and Thunder
I looked at that and I was like trailer
doesn't look very good looks kind of
cheesy looks kind of stupid we'd already
seen Thor start to kind of creep into
that in the one that he did with the
Hulk what was that one Ragnarok Ragnarok
um it was kind of a bit of adult there
and I was like I get a sense that this
is going to go even further but
it's not just one of the places that a
lot of the movie studios go to is
the reason that people aren't going to
go and watch this music this movie is
because of bigotry in one kind or
another Charlie's Angels director said
that men need enough empathy to see
movies starring women because I've been
forced to do it with men my entire life
like look you are not going to be able
to guilt people into watching your movie
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]